hello everybody and welcome to a new
amnesia custom story lost the lights
high quality version anyway your name is
Daniel you get lost in the depths of the
cold forest and you're totally lost in
the depths it's cold it's night getting
cold thinking straight is getting hard
until you find a door and without any
thought you enter it by it but entering
that place will only start the route to
hell but there is still hope find the
lights which you lost to get home ok
alright so I picked this mod because it
looked like it was more interesting it
had more varied environments actually
for when I read it used
two things from numbre it's so cold need
to find place something
okay Oh
oh rather bright
because either really tall grass or I
got really short
wonderific Daniel is still dead
Daniel
you know Daniel the murdering bastard
hello hello
we've normal
like
I tried to press e playing too much
every two monsters and cry here
loading
high quality version is a low quality
person I think that you just grab the
same textures and stuff from other ones
I'll come on there we go all right there
we go that took a while what
okay that's definitely music I don't
remember hearing amnesia
this is weird welcome to the safe maid
in 1796 renovated in 1840 we hope you
can use our technology to keep it warm
and light total population 150 we hope
you can enjoy your stay
right right okay that seems perfectly
normal
goop the goop Oh what that's a box I
thought for a second but no okay
perfectly fine oh no no no no no no no I
refuse refuse I refuse Jer save me no no
no no ya know who's in there nothing get
out of here
[Music]
note you read this note I should say I'm
sorry for you but for now there is no
time for explanations you need to go now
take the door downstairs hang on a
second I'm not going to without my
lantern excuse me chair excuse me chair
chair there we go the late reaction
chair ok lantern down tinderboxes all is
off to a creepy start
it's out there Oh what I get I uh I've
no oil for the lantern I'm not
wait what I'm so confused
you know what's said to take the door
but who I can go out this window whoa
okay here we go hey I made it oh holy
crap oh I was dragged into some sort of
room in the next time I remember I woke
up I was woken up by a lot of mannequins
okay I'm okay okay but I can't go
anywhere I don't see any see a path damn
it um maybe I need to go get some oil
before I come out here maybe I was a
little bit too great for this game doors
locked locked need to find the room key
how the crap am we gonna find then pitch
blackness okay whatever whatever huh
I'm okay I'm okay
Oh Eddie in here hey no
okay oh that's creepy that's creepy
okay so I'm guessing that this is the
way you're supposed to go but I can't
see like oh there's outline of something
there I don't know if I fall if I tried
I'm gonna probably fall to my death no
doubt no doubt I will I barely see the
outline is something there I can't see
[ __ ]
aah oh my god I made whoa oh there was a
board there okay Wow okay
whoa aw it's so skilled Oh what up yeah
[Music]
yeah yeah hey what's that I see
something down there uh oil oil oh oh oh
oil found oil oh my god this is
definitely definitely clever use of
level design oh my goodness
very very clever well
wha-oh
what was that huh like that oh I don't
know what that was
ah good huh what are you Oh Oh my God
he's just like I think it was probably
bug cuz there he is come on stop
blocking the door man hello key okay I
got a room key no oh God dark chair
protect me protect me chair seriously
Jerry don't family now when I need you
more than ever
okay I made it three in the dark I can
get back in the dark sorry that's a
sorry chair no Boosh okay how could I do
that to the chair you're probably asking
yeah I know what you're thinking oh my
goodness
uh-uh no no no no no no no no I refuse I
can't say if I forgot no no
[Music]
oh my goodness
focus Daniel this is the same Daniel
lots a naked people love it Oh Oh Big
Oil just regular oil I I'll take away
wherever I get it turn the box came
rolling out anything in here in the box
laudanum chair come with me buddy
getting out of here what I heard you
killed my best friend I don't care no I
didn't throw your friend off the edge of
the world I didn't do that
[Music]
hi Tara
Barney's [ __ ] I'll be out here come
on chair
oh my Mentos um the door doesn't look
totally blocked maybe I can open it with
some sort of item like a chair yeah ah
get open you [ __ ]
yeah Thank You chair excellent work good
teamwork and smash what oh it's always
finished never mind
jump out of that closet come on come on
don't be shy chair get out of the way
get chair hold the door
thank you key okay
strange key to the strangely locked door
I'm guessing just ajust a guess chair
come back here what oh thank you for
closing that ah dammit chair I swear
you're just screwing with me dear chair
are you on my side of their side let's
get one thing clear there's no time for
jokes okay that's right
I point you in the right direction your
Georgia
I know jujitsu not gonna give me okay
chair you wash my back okay all right
okay
Jarek you want to say there you want to
come in with me okay I got I got some of
your friends in here you just stay there
hello exactor Alexander what is that ah
ah ah oh it's so creepy
oh god it's so creepy the longer you
look at it the more creepy against uh
sanity potion good I'm going insane
hello sure okay I like you better in
those fancy fancy chairs
sir come on Oh be serious jerk okay I
just ripped it out of there like it were
nothing anyway in there
no okay all right not you
Connor come at you come on bring it on
I'm ready for you wha
huh thank you sir I think you killed him
good job chair yeah what's that
icky bless your room key is that to the
rescue room or is the key itself rusty
it's hard to tell there's something here
it's like a seam ha does it seem like
this you see it here it's like little
lines so this thing is supposed to turn
around something ah better I see you can
handle yourself quite well glad you can
one weird question
did you see the painting change if you
did something is changing you chasing
you right of you there are two sanity
potions you're gonna need it you're why
oure I have no choice to trust him I
don't have another options
this guy's grammar is terrible I don't
know if he's not English isn't his first
language or what but you can set the
mood okay chair got a good job
the monsters got in chair chair are you
okay check chair chair I can't chair
what's wrong with you
have you been exposed I shouldn't close
the door
that's our chair I'm sorry anyway that's
all the time I got for this episode
thank you guys so much for watching I am
kind of creeped out
yeah atmosphere anyway thanks again
everybody for watching I do appreciate
each and every one of you and I will see
you in the next video bye bye